what a difference a year makes
[Music]
football fans follow the european
championships in some places
even without masks bands are playing
before live audiences
and people are traveling again but is
all of that a good idea
just over a year ago the coronavirus
made the world shut down
brought death and despair
i'm seeing young patients old patients
people of all
age ranges who are just incredibly sick
and you can even hear it now
that as i'm walking through patient
rooms in the hallway
you just hear oxygen now there are
vaccines
and countries where many people have had
them more than half the population in
the worst hit country
the us in britain
that's even two-thirds after more than a
year of covet 19 we've become familiar
with complex medical terminology
difficult biological concepts but we
also realize it's not going away that
easily britain and the united states
are having trouble convincing more
people to get vaccinated
the new delta variant is spreading
rapidly
and vast regions like africa still
lack vaccines is it really time
to celebrate
[Music]
welcome to your covet 19 special i'm
chris coburn berlin
life is beginning to return to normal in
many places as the worst of the pandemic
looks like it might be behind us but
there are
spots in the world where it's a
different story like in australia where
several cities are reintroducing
restrictions
to try to contain new covet 19 clusters
some linked
to the delta variant sydney and darwin
have begun new lockdowns while other
cities are reintroducing
mask wearing only five percent of
australia's population have been fully
vaccinated
now this shows dealing and living with
the virus is still necessary
for now covet 19 isn't gone let's get
more on this
from julian tang he's a biologist and a
clinical microbiology professor at
leicester university in the uk
welcome to dw julian for more than a
year the coronavirus has determined the
daily lives of people around the globe
now you've been researching
respiratory viruses for years how is
this
virus different
hello so this virus is not really
behaving
much differently from a typical pandemic
virus entering a totally susceptible
human population
i think what's different about this
virus now is the way we can actually
study it in real time and also track all
the different complications as well as
the
case numbers death rates and
asymptomatic symptomatic uh transmission
and infection
plus also the vaccine developments and
the antiviral trials are being developed
for this pandemic now the coronavirus is
not as deadly as ebola for example nor
is difficult to combat as hiv
nevertheless it has triggered
an unprecedented global crisis
how exactly
so hiv tends to attack a certain um
group of the population and ebola again
is very
geographically confined whereas the
kerbin 19 pandemic has really affected
everybody from every country every
socio-economic
uh status individual and also
including the healthcare workers that
look after them so this is a virus that
spreads
very much more in a vein of influenza
than measles for example but it also can
cause
asymptomatic infection and is very
transmissible pre-symptomatically
which is different from the previous
sars virus back in 2003
and also different from things like
smallpox and ebola to some extent
because it can actually be transmitted
up to five days before symptom onset
and some people never develop symptoms
at all and can still spread the virus
and now we're seeing a penetration into
the younger population in primary school
secondary schools
where these children mix in classes of
20 to 30 every day five days a week
and bring the virus home to their
parents or the other adult carers
and now we're seeing much much more of a
focus on this younger population who
haven't been vaccinated yet
now the younger population being more
affected by the coronary virus is one of
the things that has
many people worried when it comes to the
delta variant
how worried are you about this mutant
so this
is more the reasons one is that it's
actually breaking through the double
dose
vaccinated individuals in the population
uh two it's come at a time when the
vaccination of the older people
has been mostly completed although we're
still seeing some breakthrough
infections there
but now it's focusing on the younger
people and the young people are the ones
who are still working
and driving the economy as well as in
full-time education
and also seeing an emergence of
long-covered
in a greater way than previously because
previously it was obscured by deaths
and hospitalization cases but now we're
seeing a lot of
long-covered emerging 30 to 50 of people
having had covered
can get long carried and this may become
a chronic healthcare burden
on the society during when the
coronavirus
started developing these variants word
among scientists was well
variants are more contagious but
probably less deadly
or less likely to trigger severe cases
is that still the case when it comes to
the delta variant
so it's a bit hard to say at the moment
and now we've got you know delta plus
with the
delta a y1 carrying the south african
417n mutation
if these variants keep emerging and
changing as we try to assess
them it's very hard to actually assign
severity uh
in a very definitive way but one aspect
that we haven't really
picked up on now that we did discuss it
last year was this idea of
antibody dependent enhancement and i was
just wondering whether the previous
immunity given by
vaccine or natural infection to the
original wuhan virus
might be reacting a different word to
these newer variants that may actually
allow some enhanced severity of illness
based on that
uh baseline of immunity induced by the
previous
uh wuhan virus natural immunity or the
vaccines which are based on that
original virus
that's something that we need to look
into now scientists have learned a lot
about the coronavirus
uh in just the course of one year and
quickly develop
effective vaccines as well what are the
things that researchers
do not yet know and that they're
specifically looking into
okay so there's just some news coming
out from the uk about the mixed
vaccine regimen which shows that if you
give one dose of the atrocities first
and then a second dose of the pfizer
uh four weeks later you get a very good
level of immunity so this mix and max
vaccine seems to work quite well and
even the reverse order seems to be quite
effective so that will help
hopefully broaden the vaccine options uh
globally but of course the many other
vaccines to try in this
the other thing is whether reinfections
or breakthrough infections
also have a a kind of higher risk or
lower risk of long covered versus just
natural infection for the first time
we're not sure what the consequences of
that reinfection would be because a lot
of the infections are milder but we
don't know whether that actually
increases or decreases the risk of
long-tailing as well
julian in your opinion have mistakes
been made in research that might have
contained the extent of the pandemic
briefly if you would
yes i think all of europe and north
america have realized that they could
have acted earlier
and more dramatically like we saw in
southeast asia and to some extent in
australia and new zealand
to lock down the virus earlier to give
time
for the vaccines to be developed and
distributed and administered
so i think countries like australia new
zealand and the southeast asian
countries
i got it right in the first part of the
pandemic but now what we're seeing is an
increased degree of vaccine hesitancy
and refusal in those same countries that
actually did very well to control the
virus
because they see the virus as less of a
threat than the vaccine adverse effects
and that change in that mentality needs
to be made to protect everybody
from ongoing replication of the virus
and the generation of new variants
julian tang of leicester university
thank you for your thoughts
thank you and now it is time to put one
of your questions to our science
correspondent derek williams
[Music]
will covet 19 variants just grow
stronger and stronger over time
this is a tough question to answer
because it assumes
that evolution is predictable which it
isn't
a mutation happens randomly
in virus genomes as they replicate
and the physical changes that those
genetic changes end up causing in the
virus
is what we mean when we talk about it
evolving
um a tiny fraction of those mutations by
just by sheer dumb luck
they'll provide variants with
evolutionary advantages of some kind
a big advantage as we've seen for
instance with the the alpha
and the delta variance of sars kovi 2
is if a variant becomes more
transmissible for some reason but
transmissibility can increase for a
range of reasons
and one is say that a variant is able to
get your cells
to make a lot more of it than your
average workaday
sars kobe 2 virus can another
would be if a variant were able to
remain
viable longer in the environment hence
increasing its chances of infecting
someone so
very different reasons same effect
see what i mean about predicting this
stuff so
when you say stronger and stronger which
i assume means
causing worse and worse disease then you
have to start by asking
whether doing so would provide a variant
with an evolutionary advantage of some
kind
and and it's hard to see how it would a
lot of virologists say
a more optimal combination of traits for
a virus
is to grow eventually more transmissible
but at the same time
less deadly because if a pathogen
doesn't kill people
they're going to be around to spread it
to others and they're more likely to let
down their guard and
infect each other with it so though we
can't predict with any
certainty what future sarskov2 variants
will look like many experts expect them
to spread
more easily but cause less severe
disease
it could well be that within 10 or 20
years
getting coveted 19 won't be any worse
for the average person than
say catching a cold is today but
because evolution isn't predictable
that's just a hopeful guess